I WE'RE GOING TO CALL THE
COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
WHEN OUR LACK OF IT WE HAVE BEEN
ABLE STARTED SAYS SUBCOMMITTEE
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE ABSENT OF A
QUORUM IN THE MEANTIME.
RICHARD BLOOM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BLOOM OR BELIEVE PER PLACING
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK.
TODAY ON THE COMMITTEE.
DO YOU HAVE AN AUTHOR HERE WILL
SEE.
PRE AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CONFLICT OWE US
SORRY I IN SEAT SORRY WE'LL
START WITH ITEM NUMBER ONE EVEN
NINETEEN OH FOUR CERVANTES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS ABOUT ISSUE MAY
OPEN.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SEVERAL LIKE
TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTED THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL
FINDING TOOLS TO INCENTIVIZE
EMPLOYERS.
ADVANTAGE OF THE UP AND COMING
WORKFORCE
KEY COMPONENTS TO TRAINING AND
MAINTAIN.
THE MIDDLE TO HIGH SKILLED
WORKFORCE.
AB NINETEEN NO FOUR WOULD ENACT
A TAX CREDIT THAT WOULD SUPPORT
THE USE OF APPRENTICESHIP
TRAINING FOR COMPANIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
WOULD ALLOW TAX CREDIT TO
EMPLOYERS AND THE NOW EQUAL TO
ONE DOLLAR FOR EACH HOUR A
REGISTERED APPRENTICE
WORKING AS TAXABLE YEAR.
THIS IS UP TO ONE THOUSAND
DOLLARS FOR MAXIM.
AND.
I TAX CREDIT WOULD DIRECTLY
INCENTIVIZE EMPLOYMENT AND ON
THE JOB TRAINING OF REGISTERED
DIFFERENT
SUITS BY MAKING APPRENTICESHIP A
MORE ATTRACTIVE. TO EMPLOYERS
I LOSAIL LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL IS
IN SUPPORT OF AB. FOR NOW I
RESPECTFULLY ASK
.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU MADAM CHAIR.
JOHNNY SMITH YOUR BEHALF.
BUILDING.
IT'S COUNCIL OR SORRY.
THAT ARE LETTER CAME IN LATE.
ANNOUNCES WE.
FOR THAT AS WELL FACE MADAM
CHAIR THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
.
WELL WE'D LIKE TO.
FOR THE COMMITTEE FOR THE
RECORD JUST KNOW THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO.
.
I SAY MANY.
MATHIS TABLING.
I LIKE TO SAY THAT WHEN IT
COMES TO THE CONSTRUCTION TRADE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS.
.
PORTANTINO THAT THERE ARE.
SOME PROGRAMS WHO DON'T GRADUATE
APPRENTICES.
AND THERE ARE SOME PROGRAMS THAT
ARE HIGH PERFORMING. AND THE
GRADUATES A GREAT NUMBER
PURPOSES. BACKED.
IN SOME AREAS OF THE
CONSTRUCTION ECONOMY IT IS.
A WAY OF DOING BUSINESS TO
IMPLEMENT PREMISES AFTER
PARTISAN.
FOR LONGER THAN THEY REALLY
SHOULD.
SO THAT YOU CAN SAVE SOME MONEY.
STRUCTURE.
SO WE WOULD.
JUST FOR THE RECORD LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW WORK WITH THAT.
AUTHOR AS THE BUILDINGS WILL
WORK
TO.
CRYSTALLIZE.
THE TYPE OF PETITIONS WERE
TALKING ABOUT A RECENT PICTURE.
SO THE ONLY MAINLY ARE ONLY HIGH
PERFORMING.
THE FRAZIER PROGRAMS YOUR AFTER
GRADUATING FROM THE.
OUR. ELIGIBLE.
HAVE. A BETTER SHOT AT GETTING A
TAX CREDIT
BECAUSE THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
WHEN IT COMES TO SIT. SHIP.
FOR THOSE REASONS.
AND WITH THAT COUNT YET WE ARE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TALKING
ROOM SITE FOR THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA CONTRACTORS
SEE ISSUES WE ARE SUPPORT.
I'M R. MEMBERS HAVE SIGNED
MASTER LABOR AGREEMENTS.
VARIOUS UNIONS THEY'RE HAVING
ENGINEERING BECAUSE.
OF THIS WOULD BE A BETTER.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
OPPOSITION.
ONE THING TO PLACE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BREAK.
THANK YOU WERE A MEMBER CHAD
LIKE TO.
.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK.
AND WE NEED A LOT MORE OF THESE
AYE INCREMENTAL EFFORTS TOWARDS
GETTING A SKILLED TRAINED
WORKFORCE WE'VE GOT A CRISIS
GOING ON THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
ARE OBVIOUSLY THIS CONTRIBUTING
TO A SUMMER ECONOMIC WOES IS
CONTRIBUTING TO OUR HOUSING
CRISIS.
WHICH OF COURSE RESULT IN
HOMELESSNESS ISSUE AND. OTHER SO
IT'S GREAT TO SEE. YOU TAKING
STEPS
TO ON.
ADDRESS THE WORK FOR SHORTAGE OF
A DIFFERENT BILL FOR NOT BE
SUPPORTED TODAY.
AND I QUESTIONS.
JAKE CLOSE.
RESPECT FOR ABSTRACT ABOUT.
AND ARE YOU ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
SECOND.
GROWING FOR A QUORUM SO WILL
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION AS SOON AS
WE HAVE ONE.
MOVING TO ITEM THREE AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE COVER YOUR OWN.
YOU MAY OPEN.
MEMBERS OF THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND PLEASE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWENTY THREE. WHICH WILL
MAKE UP FOR SOME THINK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THE FOR
THEIR WORK ON THIS SPELL. AB
TWENTY TWENTY THREE WILL MAKE
THAT STATE CHILD AND DEPENDENT
CARE EXPENSES CREDIT REFUNDABLE.
SO THAT LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
WORKING FAMILIES CAN BENEFIT
FROM THE CREDIT TO ASSIST WITH
THEIR CHILD CARE EXPENSES.
CALIFORNIA CHILD AND DEPENDENT
CARE EXPENSES CREDIT ALLOWS
TAXPAYERS WITH INCOMES BELOW ONE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS TO
REDUCE THEIR TAX LIABILITY BY A
CERTAIN PERCENTAGE OF THEIR LA.
ELIGIBLE CHILDCARE EXPENSES IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN THE STATE
MADE THAT CREDIT NON REFUNDABLE
DUE TO BUDGET SHORTFALLS WHAT
THAT MEANS IS THAT THE NON
REFUNDABLE CREDIT ONLY PROVIDES
BENEFITS. TO FAMILIES THAT.
STATE INCOME TAXES WHICH MEANS
THAT LOW AND MODERATE INCOME
FAMILIES ARE EXCLUDED EVEN
THOUGH THEY FACE RISING
CHILDCARE EXPENSES BASICALLY IF
YOU EARN UNDER FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS YOU DON'T. GENERALLY OWE
TAXES AND SO YOU CAN'T CLAIM
THIS.
.
THIS IS A CREDIT UP WE KNOW THAT
THE COST OF CHILDCARE IS
EXPENSIVE. AND IS AN INCREASING
BURDEN FOR CALIFORNIA'S WORKING
FAMILIES FROM THE MOST URBAN TO
MOST RURAL COUNTIES.
CHILDCARE COSTS ARE SOARING.
AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE WILL HELP
WORKING FAMILIES MEET THE
ECONOMIC CHALLENGES OF RAISING A
FAMILY AND ACCESSING QUALITY
CHILDCARE. MAKING THE CREDIT
REFUNDABLE AGAIN WILL PUT MONEY
BACK IN THE POCKETS OF WORKING
FAMILIES SO THAT THEY CAN PAY
FOR BASIC NEEDS LIKE FOOD
HOUSING AND MEDICAL CARE. HERE
WITH ME THEY DETEST FINDS IN
SUPPORT I HAVE MICHELLE STILL
WELL APARTMENTS KEY FROM THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA. AND CATIA AND SAY IT
AND SAY WE FROM CALIFORNIA
CHILDCARE RESOURCE AND REFERRAL
NECK NETWORK I THINK I'M GONNA
ASK YOU JUST HOLD ON ONE SECOND
WHILE WE HAVE A QUORUM.
WE CAN TAKE THEIR OFF.
BURKE
THERE.
BROUGH ALLEN BONTA.
CHIU.
GRAY HERE ACCARDI.
MELENDEZ MULLIN BLOOM.
COR.
CUBA HAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WISH ALSO PREVENTS
PEOPLE IF THE.
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE PROUD
THE SPONSOR AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE.
THE CALIFORNIA TRIAL
INDEPENDENT.
THERE EXPENSES TAX CREDIT IS
BASED ON THE FEDERAL CREDIT AND
SOME OF THEIR CHILD CARE COST.
WHICH WE AS WE KNOW ARE RISING.
UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT CREDIT
FAILS TO REACH MANY LOW INCOME
FAMILIES BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
REMOVED THE REFUND ABILITY IN
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN.
THAT MEANS A FAMILIES YOU DON'T
HAVE STATE TAX LIABILITY EVEN
THOUGH THEY ARE PAYING OTHER
TAXES LIKE PROPERTY AND SALES
TAX
ARE UNABLE TO BENEFIT.
AS MENTIONED FAMILIES EARNING
UNDER ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR AREN'T ABLE TO
BENEFIT FROM THE CREDIT AND LEAD
TO THE FAMILIES WHO ARE
STRUGGLING THE MOST TO PAY FOR
RISING CHILD CARE.
UNDER AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE
ALONE CAN FAMILY COULD RECEIVE A
REFUNDABLE CREDIT OF UP TO A
THOUSAND AND FIFTY DOLLARS
WHICH IS ONLY A SMALL PORTION OF
WHAT CHILD CARE COSTS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. BUT WOULD MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE FOR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES IN THEIR BUDGET.
A ROBUST BODY OF RESEARCH SHOWS
THE BENEFITS OF REFUNDABLE TAX
CREDITS
ESPECIALLY FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES.
PART IT'S LIKE THE EARNED
INCOME TAX CREDIT IN THE CHILD
TAX CREDIT.
HE'S CREDIT INCREASE FAMILIES
ECONOMIC RESOURCES AND ALSO.
TO IMPROVE CHILD OUTCOMES CHILD
HEALTH AND.
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES.
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES EVEN A
SLIGHT INCREASE IN FAMILY INCOME
MAKES A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE
EVEN INTO ADULTHOOD FOR THOSE
CHILDREN.
AND GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT
THE.
PARTICULAR HARMLESS THAT CHILD
POVERTY HAS ON YOUNG CHILDREN
FUN DISCREDIT AND IT'S.
FOCUS ON. ON CHILD CARE WOULD
BE BENEFICIAL.
MAKING A CREDIT REFUNDABLE WOULD
ALSO BE HELPFUL IN TERMS OF
DECREASING THE COST OF CHILD
CARE FOR FAMILIES.
WHICH MADE SAID BY SOME TO. TO
WORK
AS WELL AND WE KNOW THAT THIS
CREDIT IS ACTUALLY ONLY
AVAILABLE FOR CHILDCARE EXPENSES
THAT ARE REALLY.
AND FINALLY AB TWENTY TWENTY
THREE MAKES A SMALL STEP TOWARDS
MAKING THE TAX CODE MORE
APPLICABLE. WE KNOW RIGHT NOW
THAT LOW INCOME FAMILIES TO A
HIGHER PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
INCOME IN.
TAXES STATE AND LOCAL TAXES AND
THIS WOULD HELP REBALANCE THAT.
.
SO FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS AV
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THE LONG
OVERDUE POLICY THAT WILL HELP
WORKING FAMILIES SUPPORT LOW
INCOME CHILDREN. AND PROMOTE
EQUITY.
WE URGE I THINK.
CAROLINE BIRD MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. GOOD AFTERNOON LADIES
CAN YOU SAFELY WE.
OUT THERE RESOURCE.
NETWORK.
AND PAIN THAT CO DIRECTOR.
SEE AN INTERROGATION.
WE ARE MEMBERSHIP ORGANIZATION
EVERY OUR IN OUR
CALIFORNIA.
WELL HARD OURS INITIAL PURPOSE
FORTY YEARS AGO WAS TO CONNECT
FAMILIES TO THE CHILD CARE THAT
THE.
TODAY AMONG MANY OTHER THINGS
ARE IN OURS HAD THE CAPABILITY
OF FAMILIES ACCESS THE CARE THEY
NEED WHEN AND WHERE THE.
THE JURY PLUS
YEAH A MAJOR BARRIER TO USING
LICENSE.
WHERE IS COST?
ACCORDING TO OUR RECENTLY
RELEASED TWENTY SEVENTEEN
CALIFORNIA CHILD CARE PORTFOLIO
THE AVERAGE ANNUAL COST OF
CENTER BASED CARE REDUCE FROM
ELEVEN THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
DOLLARS A YEAR.
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND THREE.
AND THE COST OF FAMILY CHILD
CARE HOME CARE IS SEVEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS TO FOURTEEN THOUSAND
FOUR HUNDRED DOLLARS.
BUT EVERY CHILD CARE CONCEDE
GOT.
UP TO A THIRD OF THE FAMILY'S
MONTHLY BUDGETS AND LOWER INCOME
SPACE LOWER INCOME FAMILIES FACE
A MUCH HEAVIER BURDEN.
YEAH CALIFORNIA'S ONLY TO SERVE
ONE IN SEVEN CHILDREN WHO
QUALIFY.
SUCH AS.
SO VERY TRUE INCOME ELIGIBLE FOR
SUBSIDIES BUT DOES NOT RECEIVE
LINE WILL STAY. OVER FORTY
PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME
PER CHILD CARE.
AND THOSE SAME FAMILIES ARE
LIKELY TO QUALIFY FOR A REFUND
FROM THE CHILD. CARE.
EXPENSES CREDIT SHOULD AB TWENTY
TWENTY THREE BECOME LAW.
THIS BILL WOULD MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT LOSS BROWN BY
REINSTATING THE RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT CALIFORNIA'S CREDIT.
THIS IMPROVEMENT WILL HELP THE
FAMILIES WHO NEED THE MOST HELP
PAY FOR CHILD CARE.
UNLIKE SOME OTHER STATE
CHILDCARE CREDIT. CALIFORNIA
CHILD AND DEPENDENT CARE
EXPENSES CREDIT AS WELL
STRUCTURED SO THAT IT DOESN'T
KNOW ABOUT THE LOWEST INCOME.
WHILE ONCE A YEAR FEDERAL
CREDIT.
TWO MONTHS EXPENSE.
OF CHILD CARE REFUND FOR THOSE
FAMILIES WHO QUALIFY WILL BE A
MEANINGFUL INFUSION OF CASH.
TO HELP THEM WITH THE COST OF
CARE AND THE MONEY THEY RECEIVE.
SO AB TWENTY TWENTY THREE WILL
SUPPORT WORKING FAMILIES TO
CONTINUE TO DO EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO PROVIDE TO THEIR
HOUSEHOLDS.
WELL ALLOWING THEM TO KEEP THEIR
CHILDREN IN THE CHILD CARE SAY
THEY GO ONLINE.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ATTACK.
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES UP IN
SUPPORT.
DOCTOR HERE RAVEN OUT WAS HE
CAPTURES CALIFORNIA.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
DON'T EVER BREAK.
A NUMBER OF THE BILL.
SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE.
I BURKE GUY BRO. ALLEN BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHU. CHU ARE AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY. CURRY AYE
MELINDA'S
MULLIN BLOOM.
BILLS PASSED.
THAT FILL IT OUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
WE'LL GO BACK TO.
ITEM ONE.
WHICH IS AB NINETEEN OH BEFORE.
CERVANTES.
BUT WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND THE BILL.
THAT WILL TAKE A VOTE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS WAS
APPROACH TO PASS WAS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BURKE AYE AYE
BURKE AYE GROW ALLEN. BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE GRAY AYE GRAY AYE
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S
POLAND THE BLOOM.
LOOK SIX AT ZERO.
THAT ITEM IS OUT. SIX TWO ZERO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOLACE A BEAT
TWO ZERO ZERO EIGHT.
YOU MAY OPEN. ITEM NUMBER TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FIRST OFF LET
ME START BY THANKING YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT THEY'VE DONE LOOK FOR TO
ACCEPTING THEIR COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND REALLY APPRECIATE
ABOUT OF CHAIRWOMAN YOU ADDING
ON AS A JOINT AUTHOR.
AND WHAT EXTEND THAT OFFER TO
ANYBODY ELSE ON THE COMMITTEE IF
THEY'D LIKE TO ADD ON AS WELL AS
A CO AUTHORS.
AB TWO THOUSAND IT WOULD HELP
TO IMPROVE AIR QUALITY THE STATE
BY EXEMPTING GRANTS RECEIVED
FROM THE CARL MOYER MEMORIAL AIR
QUALITY STANDARDS TEMA PROGRAM
FROM STATE INCOME TAX.
PROGRAM ASSIST BUSINESS OWNERS
AND PUBLIC AGENCIES TO REPLACE
HIGH POLLUTING VEHICLES WITH
CLEANER A MISSION REDUCING
ENGINES.
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE ARE DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED BY AIR QUALITY ISSUES
IN THE STATE HAS MADE GREAT
STRIDES TO MEET ITS GOAL BECAUSE
OF PROGRAMS LIKE THIS.
HOWEVER THE PROGRAM A STRUGGLE
TO GET SMALL BUSINESS AND
INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE IN
THE PROGRAM GIVEN THE HIGH
UPFRONT COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
ACCEPTING THE GRANT.
BY EXEMPTING THE GRANT FROM
STATE INCOME TAX AB TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT WOULD CREATE AN ADDITIONAL
INCENTIVE FOR SMALL BUSINESSES.
AND INDIVIDUALS TO PARTICIPATE
AND HELP OUR STATE BEAT ITS AIR
QUALITY GOALS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR.
AND I VOTING I DO HAVE A
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT.
ANDCARE MEMBERS THAT MADE MY
NEXT TIME JORDAN I'M WITH THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT.
I WE'VE MASTERED THE CARL MOYER
PROGRAM IN THE EIGHT COUNTIES TO
THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY.
THIS PROGRAM HAS BEEN A GREAT
TOOL AND DIE IN ORDER TO GET
EMISSION REDUCTIONS FROM HEAVY
DUTY MOBILE EQUIPMENT.
BOTH IN THE SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY
THE SOUTH COAST WHERE WE HAVE
TREMENDOUS AIR QUALITY
CHALLENGES HEAVY EQUIPMENT THE
SINGLE LARGEST EMISSION SOURCE
THAT WE HAVE TO CONTROL THE
CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS.
AND WHILE THE PROGRAM HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD REACHING OUT
TO MORE AND MORE SMALL
BUSINESSES AND PEOPLE THAT.
THE UP FRONT COST IS REALLY AN
ISSUE WHILE IT IS A GRANT
PROGRAM WHEN PEOPLE PARTICIPATE
IN A CAR LAWYER PROGRAM
OFTENTIMES IF TAKING A PIECE OF
EQUIPMENT THAT WORKS JUST FINE
FOR THEM NOW. AND THEY HAVE TO
SCRAP THAT PIECE OF EQUIPMENT
WHEN THEY PURCHASE A NEW PIECE
OF EQUIPMENT THAT'S LOWER
EMISSIONS.
SO THERE'S QUITE A BIT OF COST
ASSOCIATED WITH IT WITH IT THE
GRANTS TYPICALLY ONLY PAY FOR
ABOUT HALF THE COST OF THE NEW
PIECE OF EQUIPMENT.
AND SO. YEAH MORE MORE OFTEN
WERE WRITING TO PEOPLE THAT ARE
BASICALLY SAYING WE'D LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE ABOUT THE UP FRONT
COST ARE JUST TOO MUCH SO WE
THINK THIS IS A. SENSIBLE WAY I
TO MAKE SURE THE PROGRAMS
REACHING ALL THE FOLKS AS WAS
MENTIONED.
THE VALLEY'S HOME TO TWENTY TO
THIRTY MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE.
AND WE'RE REALLY TRYING TO
REACH OUT TO THOSE COMMUNITIES
AND AND GET A MAJOR REDUCTIONS
IN THOSE AREAS WE THINK THIS
WILL BE VERY HELPFUL. SO WE ASK
FOR YOUR YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY
TWO ZERO ZERO.
I THINK YOU ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
BOTTOM CHAIR MEMBERS BRING INTO
IT ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION. OTHER CARL MOYER
PROGRAM IS A HIGHLY SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM COST EFFECTIVE AYE WE
THINK THIS PROPOSAL WILL MAKE IT
EVEN MORE ACCESSIBLE AND DATA WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT.
LUCKILY MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHECK OF MY AWESOME TO HAVE A
SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
AND I ECHO WHAT PRINCE AND THANK
YOU.
I MET ROMAN CATHOLIC TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF OF
THE WESTERN PROPANE GAS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT THINKING.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE SO
NEVER TO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SHARMA THEN
CHAIR JUST WANTED TO SAY HAPPY
BIRTHDAY RUDY I WAS STAFF AND
ALL SUPPORT A BILL.
APPRECIATE THAT.
SO MEMBERS RIGHT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU.
SOMERSAULTS BRING THIS FORWARD I
KNOW WE'VE PARTNERED TOGETHER ON
A LOT OF THESE EFFORTS TO DEAL
WITH. EMISSIONS AIR QUALITY IN
THE VALLEY A IT'S.
I CAN'T MISS THE OPPORTUNITY
MIND ARE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
THE LEGISLATURE'S ALL. ON THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY SUFFERS TO
SOME OF THE WORST AIR QUALITY
ISSUES IN THE COUNTRY. NOT JUST
IN THE STATE A AS LONG AS WELL
AS ON SOME OF THE HIGHEST
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES POVERTY.
IN THE COUNTRY AND SO I ANY
EFFORT TO.
MADE COMMISSION REDUCTIONS IN
AIR QUALITY ISSUES MORE
AFFORDABLE AND AND HAVE A
GREATER IMPACT.
IS AN IMPORTANT EFFORT I THANK
YOU FOR THE BILL AND ALL I'LL BE
SUPPORTING IT TODAY.
YOU.
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
BUT I JUST WANT TO REVIEW THE
AMENDMENTS AGREED UPON THAT'S
CLARIFYING THAT ALL MONETARY
GRANTS UNDER THE PROGRAM ARE
EXEMPT FROM STATE INCOME TAX.
ALLOWS FTP TO VERIFY THE CLAIMED
EXCLUSION AMOUNTS PROVIDE A FIVE
YEAR SUNSET DATE DISALLOWS
TAXPAYERS FROM CLAIMING MULTIPLE
TAX BENEFITS FOR THE SAME ITEM
AND EXPENSE. IT AS ME AS A JOINT
AUTHORS SOMETHING TO GROW AND
FOR THAT OUR JOINT AUTHORED.
BUT I I REITERATE WHAT ARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WELL HAPPY
BIRTHDAY SORRY REITERATE WHAT
THEY BOTH SAY IS THAT.
THEY'RE GREAT CHALLENGES IN THE
VALLEY AND AND THIS IS ONE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO ALLEVIATE
SOME OF THE BURDEN AS WE TRANSIT
AS WE TRANSLATE OUR.
VEHICLES AND OUR TRUCKS.
AND OUR EQUIPMENT INTO
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY. AB
MACHINERY IT'S IT IT'S A
CHALLENGED AREA AND THIS PROGRAM
HAS PROVEN TO BE VERY SUCCESSFUL
AND SO I AM VERY GLAD THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS AND GLAD TO BE
A CO AUTHOR WITH THAT. YOU MAY
CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
WILL TAKE ALL OF YOUR COMMENTS
AS MY CLOTHES.
THAT WE CAN TAKE THE OATH.
SECOND.
WHO GAVE THE SECOND?
AND SECOND VISIT.
OKAY.
MOTION THAT I'M GRAY SECOND BY
MCCARTY THAT WILL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PROCESS A
MANITOBA CREATIONS BURKE AYE
BURKE AYE ROLE.
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BONTA BONTA RHS
YOU. CHIU AYE GRAY AYE GRAY AYE
MCCARTY. CURTI I MELINDA THIS.
MULLIN BLOOM.
BLOOM I KNOW THAT SAT BILL IT'S
OUT CONGRATULATIONS AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY AGAIN THANK YOU.
NOT ON.
FOR MORE.
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB NINETEEN OH
FOUR ALLEN NOT VOTING.
AND ITEM NUMBER TWO TWO OF TWO
THREE BY
ZERO.
ALLEN NOT KNOW.
WE ARE ADJOURNED